ich war gerade schon eigentlich wollte
ich ja gar kein blog machen mein gott da
ist ein pickel eigentlich wollte ich
einfach machen doch dann habe ich mir
ganz genau
ihr freut euch bestimmt oder auch nicht
cool
heute ist dass ich gleich erstmal max
abhole wieder zusammen in re gefahren wo
wir dann ekelhafte getränke kaufen weil
ich danach eine challenge mit anderen
youtube anmache wir dürfen die frage
ganz in weiß passiert hier nicht so
häufig dass auf meinem kanal tatsächlich
mal anregen werden erkältung sterben
jogginghose weiße tennissocken anschlag
t shirt jeans jacke
nein für mich das beste ist deswegen der
jungen ist super was haben wir
eigentlich und dass du fragst für die
kommission die kaufkraft paar sachen ein
die waschcenter zitronen gemischt
irgendwie sowas um mission das nachher
zusammen dann machen wir eine e-klasse
challenge mit kleinen youtube und ohne
wachstum wirklich lukrativ ente
aufnahmen von landschaften kann dazu
geil da hab ich gerade das was mich zu
den historischen a
das zeigt euch erstmal mein büro freunde
was trinken rechtsgut oder muss wegen
bin ich auch so gesund wie eine
fernbedienung mit der fernbedienung kann
ich dagegen draußen
es ist wichtig dass technik funktioniert
dass nichts passiert ja was will man da
halo das machst du dann nicht jeden tag
also bat der machtkampf bereits als auch
gut man muss immer so die ziele vor
augen wischen aber nachher ist ist ganz
normal in meinem büro zeigt euch jetzt
mal ein auto fährt
weißt du eigentlich wie du bist keine
ahnung wann ich bin brücken machen so
bot ihm eine laser luca wir sind auf dem
boden haben ja immer gibt übel
anstrengend überall wo kinder aus dem
messer alter das tempo
die haben alle messer alle bin ich bin
sehr gut gefällt ja du bist auch die
größte wundertüte 2 hätte das von dir ja
schmeckt sehr gut das bringt ihren wagen
nicht mehr ist und was machen wir das
und zwar gibt es immer
ach so ja klar denn willkommen doch es
gibt auch draußen sachen wie man darauf
genau darauf hin das ist nicht unbedingt
mit den fragen ja genau
herr sebastian ja ja ja
zwischendrin kann man schon sagen dass
coop ensemble sag ich mal zu meinem
größten hobbys gehört dann flaschen auch
oder im näheren familienkreis habe ich
das ehrlich leute die davon betroffen
sind okay aber jetzt direkt nebenan
wohnt keiner ich kann dazu nur soviel
sagen entweder man kann dieses auto ist
für mich aber wie viele kilometer fahren
sie denn wenn ich ehrlich bin muss ich
das wirklich sein wenn ich ehrlich bin
muss ich ganz glücklich sein ist ein
dummkopf wenn das album das er sich das
haarwachstum eine karte bekommt es jetzt
ja wir machen jetzt radio mit video auch
also fernsehen in graz teams für freddy
auf und also das hat unser helikopter
von max mir und dass unsere zahnbürste
findet und seife interview mit sturm ja
danke für das interview gast
vielleicht wird man vor kurzem
angefangen zu studieren ist gerade auch
weil man sagt der probieren geht über
studieren
ich fange an zu studieren wo ich einfach
probieren könntest du malta
das bisschen doof in essen ich mache es
selbst der kamera
laser luca ich habe bilder drin alles
klar george du bist hässlich eine
scheiße ja ja nico wie gefällt dir die
zeit bisher so ein controller ist eine
couch gemütlich oder ich habe hier ein
kondom für dich vorbereitet ich okay
danke fürs interview
wir sind jetzt fertig mitdrehen im ufo
und fahren jetzt nach hause das an
einigen stellen ein wenig daran dass ich
werde definitiv dafür sorgen dass regel
nie wieder meinen blogs vorkommt die
hier von hand zusammen update hier
laufen doch nicht zum pub weil risi und
die stuttgarter die tat ab alt sind und
sie laufen jetzt zum piano kinder sind
übrigens wachsen denn jetzt neben gibt
was das max
er erzählt die geschichte der prinz
das war richtig
am 11 12 luca mio shop.de so wir gehen
jetzt die ganz kurz das spiel kaufen
jetzt 23 fühlt sich wohl gerade
o
sie fand zu unseren waschbecken
einkaufen das ding ist ich habe keine
wahl stellt weiß ganz ehrlich - kommt es
immer geil aktions nachts immer
schneller beschäftigte erwartet voll
spaß immer man denke nicht dass er so
viel papier ist tatsächlich dieser
stelle gern verkünden dass die akkus
laden herzlich ein
auf den kanälen sind in gefahr ich
spenden und nicht zuletzt einfach sascha
volk analog auf install und der beste
blocker meine damen und herren erhitzt
zu hause sind seiner 500 quadratmeter
villa angekommen ich hoffe euch hat
dieser block gefeiert werde damen und
herren er war so ein bisschen anders als
normalen blogs dich mal hochladen also
dieser blockverhalten ja so dumme sachen
aneinander gekettet und so weiter und so
fort wenn euch dieser look gefallen hat
heute dann lasst doch gerne mal ein like
dafür die mehr davon sehen wollt dann
lade ich davon dementsprechend dann halt
einfach weniger hoch sonst bin ich an
der schule sagen ja das habe ich einfach
nichts wird bitte nutzt nur in ordnung
und um ein video wie der typ ist